welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this video is sponsored by imax
doctor strange of the multiverse of
madness released a new poster
highlighting that this film was film for
imax which i'm super excited for i woke
up super early when tickets went on sale
to make sure i got an imax ticket
because you knew when we watched this
movie the best parts of it are gonna be
in the edges of the frame i know i sound
crazy but i am the kind of guy who goes
to art museums and just admires the
edges of the frames and the frames
themselves sometimes like who cares if
the mona lisa is smiling or not look at
her hands look at her hands this new
imax creative for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness has a beautiful
design to it that i just really have to
break down because the reality is that
doctor strange the multiverse madness
was shot with imax cameras the entire
film is finished with a 1.90 aspect
ratio exclusively for imax the artwork
contains visual elements pulled from the
world of the film so let's analyze this
poster to see what we can see pick a
parrot with the recent bromo imagery
with characters weapons popping out of
the frame proving just how important
it'll be to see this movie in the imax
aspect ratio so on each of the four
letters of imax i-m-a-x is an
interesting texture that matches the
carvings on the back wall of what i and
other fans have speculated to be the
dark-holed temple on wundergore mountain
the place in marvel lore where c'thun
drafted the darkhold and where in this
movie a major set piece is going to take
place with wanda wong america chavez and
at least two of those demonic beasts
that i've speculated might be cathons
and garai minions specifically on that a
is a circular starburst pattern that not
only appears in the back wall of that
setting but also appears behind the
scarlet witch in ink on that page in the
darkhold book in episode nine of one
division it's your destiny to destroy
the world
it's almost like c'thun or whoever
drafted that page in particular drew
this doodle as a kind of fever-dream
premonition of what they foresaw in the
destiny of the scarlet witch for her to
return to this particular spot and for
that particular carving atop that
particular altar an altar adorned with
the same horned head sigil that covers
the dark cold book cover we're judging
the book by the cover here folks because
it could all mean that it needs to be in
this particular spot where wanda will
say the magic words that in that
forecast read by agatha harkness will
destroy this world this universe but in
doing so transform it to the way it out
to be one with mutants in it one of the
crazier new shots from the promo footage
shows wanna get in entombed in a mirror
dimension prism but unlike other mirror
dimensions that we've seen in the mcu
this one has broken mir shard's spikes
poking up around her almost like the
breaking of reality made the mirror
dimension an even more dangerous pocket
dimension to occupy and we should be
reminded of the mere dimension grand
canyon battle in spider-man no way home
when strange's cloak of levitation
tugged peter parker's foot to try to
pull him apart from that macadavis
through an endless array of sling ring
portals but in that tug of war the sides
of the mirrored dimension got sandwiched
together until the whole thing
completely obliterated into pieces i
don't think that was supposed to happen
and it caused the mirror dimension to
get so messed up that even doctor
strange couldn't calculate the geometry
of it it's also not clear if the mirror
dimension was ever put back into proper
order after that now in that battle
you'll remember strange controlled the
mirror dimension initially by using this
ayah of agamoto the new one in this
movie there was an easy to miss shot of
that eye necklace opening and glowing
golden as it does in close-ups of this
new footage showing individual glowing
particles orbiting around something
meaning that this eye will have new
functions in this movie so i think now
that the mirror dimension is a
permanently fractured realm like if you
imagine this was designed for sorcerers
to be able to get lost or to lose each
other in a kind of hall of mirrors of
their own creation essentially now
someone has fired a machine gun into
that hall of mirrors making it a
nightmare maze of broken glass kind of
like what happens in your kitchen when
you're a little kid and you drop your
favorite tom and jerry's welch's
collectible glass on the ground and it
shatters
and your parent comes and goes ah
little eric you ain't got shoes on don't
you move i grew up in the south that's
how we talked this is just me trying to
explain why i think much of this movie's
marketing including this imax poster is
so centered around the broken glass
aesthetic in fact another really cool
design detail in this artwork is the way
each broken shard refracts the letters
disintegrated in different ways the
shard on the left shows the m melting
into that inky goo like the buildings of
new york and the various overcast shots
of the city and trailer footage another
shard over the m and the a shows cleaner
breaks but an additional layer of the
letter a also breaking behind it just a
cool way of showing how when you're a
nexus being and one of you breaks all of
use breaks the shard spanning the a and
the x is a reference to the floral
pattern column seen at multiple points
in the trailer there's another clean
break on the other side of the a with
the x but then on the top half of the x
that shard shows that x breaking apart
by splitting into blocks just like how
doctor strange and american chavez look
and that amazing shot from the trailer
we also learned from recent footage that
strange will say this line in the movie
this is the only way which is a direct
callback to his final words to tony
stark before he dusted an infinity war
on the planet titan there was no other
way so whatever violations to natural
law dr strange committed in the past
that got him into this mess like what he
did in infinity war and in-game the
doctor is gonna have to break the
universe even more to fix it and i can't
wait to see him do it especially seeing
them do this in imax because if you're
not experiencing it in imax you're not
seeing the whole picture folks and imax
sound is gonna be the best way to
experience danny elfman's score like i
don't know if you saw footage from him
rocking out at coachella but hearing the
themes of this movie along with sam
raimi's imagery shot with imax cameras
it's just gonna be a mind-blowing
experience i can't wait for it so be
sure to click the link in the
description to get your imax multiverse
of madness tickets opening may 6. follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
following the rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you